مشاهدينا ونتابع هذه الصور من منطقه غازي
عنتاب مع موفد العربي عبد المحسن الحربي
الذي رصد لحظه صمت تقوم بها الفرق
السعوديه او تطلب تطالبها الفرق السعوديه
في محيط هذه هذا المبنى لان هناك امل
للعثور على احد الناجين في هذه المنطقه
لتبعد مشاهدينا هذه الصور من هذه المنطقه
التي تتواجد فيها الفرق السعوديه وهي لحظه
صمت ترصدها كاميرا العربيه مع مراسلنا او
موفد عبد المحسن الحربي للحظه الصمت تطالب
بها وتنظمها ايضا وتجريها الفرق الاغاثيه
السعوديه عملا في العثور على احد الناجين
والسماع الصوت استغاثه ربما في هذه
اللحظات العصيبه مازن معكم اذا في متابعه
هذه العمليات عمليه الانقاذ والبحث عن
ناجين بين الانقاض عقب هذا زلزال الكبير
الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا يوم
الاثنين الماضي بشده س درجات فاصله ثمانيه
نذكر مشاهدينا ان
جهودا كبير تبدلها فرق الانقاذ من دول
العربيه وعالميه في المناطق المتضرره منها
الفرق السعوديه كما ان الحمل الشعبي
السعودي لاغاثه منكوبي زلزال سوريا وتركيا
تجاوزت التبرعات عبر عام
2007 مليون ريال حتى الان في حين ايضا
عبرت احدى عشره شاحنه من المساعدات
السعوديه الى الداخل السوري عبر منفذ باب
الحمام الحدودي وحموله هذه الشاحنات من
المساعدات تبلغ 104 اطنان تشمل مساعدات
اغاثيه ودوائيه وغذائيه وسيتم بطبيعه
الحال توزيعها في المناطق الاكثر تضررا في
شمال غربي سوريا الان هذه الصور المشاهدين
اتابعها مباشره من غازي عنتاب
ولحظه صمت ترصدها كاميرا العربيه تحت
اشراف الف الاغاثيه
والانقاريه السعوديه املا في العثور على
ناجين تحت ركامي هذا المبنى الذي انهار في
منطقه غازي عنتاب بفعل الزلزال المدمر اذا
الفرق السعوديه
الاغاثيه تطلب لحظه صمت املا في العثور
على الناجين تحت الانقاض بغازي عنتاب